>> JEFF ZELENY IS IN JACKSON,
WYOMING.
THIS WAS A LANDSLIDE VICTORY FOR
HARRIET HAGEMAN.
NOT SO LONG AGO, SHE WAS A
POLITICAL ALLY OF LIZ CHENEY'S.
OBVIOUSLY NOT THE CASE NOW.
>> Reporter: DEFINITELY THAT IS
ONE OF THE MANY EVOLUTIONS WE
HAVE LEARNED IN THIS WYOMING
RACE.
HARRIET HAGEMAN INTRODUCED LIZ
CHENEY WHEN SHE WAS FIRST
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS BACK IN
2016 AS MY FRIEND, AND AS A
PROVEN CONSERVATIVE.
OF COURSE, LIZ CHENEY WON THAT
RACE THE SAME NIGHT THAT DONALD
TRUMP WON IN 2016, SO MUCH HAS
CHANGED INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY SINCE THEN.
AND WE REALLY LEARNED HOW MUCH
WITH THAT MARGIN OF DEFEAT.
THEY KNEW THEY WERE ON THE WAY
TO LOSING THE PRIMARY.
BUT THE MARRIAGGIN WAS SOMETHIN
THAT SURPRISED MANY CHENEY
SUPPORTERS.
WE'RE LEARNING WHAT LIZ CHENEY'S
NEXT STEPS ARE GOING TO BE FOR
NOW.
OVERNIGHT, HER CAMPAIGN FILED
PAPERS WITH THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMITTEE TO CREATE A LEADERSHIP
PAC.
THAT ALLOWS HER SIMPLY TO RAISE
AND SPEND MONEY TRAVELING ACROSS
THE CAN COUNTRY TO DO WHAT SHE
WANTS TO DO, TO TAKE ON THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
SHE IS CALLING THE LEADERSHIP
PAC THE GREAT TASK.
BUT SHE SAID ON THE "TODAY" SHOW
ABOUT HER FLOPLANS FOR 2024.
>> ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> THAT'S A DECISION I'M GOING
TO MAKE IN THE COMING MONTHS.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE ANY
ANNOUNCEMENTS HERE THIS MORNING,
BUT IT IS SOMETHING I'M THINKING
ABOUT AND I'LL MILWAUKEE A
DECMAKE
A DECISION IN THE COMING MONTHS.
>> Reporter: WHEN SHE SAYS THE
COMING MONTHS, THAT MEANS AFTER
SHE LEAVES HER CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT.
FOR THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS SHE IS
GOING TO BE IN CONGRESS, OF
COURSE, AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
AND I'M TOLD BY PEOPLE FAMILIAR
WITH HER THINKING IS THAT SHE
DOES NOT WANT TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT RIGHT NOW AS THE
COMMITTEE IS STILL DOING ITS
WORK.
SHE, OF COURSE, IS LEADING THE
CHARGE ON THAT.
BUT IF SHE WOULD DECIDE TO RUN,
THAT WOULD COME NEXT YEAR.
AND, AGAIN, BACK TO THE TITLE OF
THE GREAT TASK, OF COURSE, SHE
IS REFERRING TO ABRAHAM
LINCOLN'S GETTYSBURG ADDRESS,
WHICH HE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES FACING THE COUNTRY,
THE GREAT TASK.
AND THAT WAS IN HER SPEECH LAST
EVENING AS WELL.
A SPEECH THAT WAS INFUSED WITH
HISTORY.
BUT NOW HISTORY FOR HER IS THAT
HER CONGRESSIONAL SEAT WILL COME
TO A CLOSE AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR AND IT REALLY IS THE END OF
A LEGACY FOR THE CHENEY FAMILY
HERE IN WYOMING AS WELL.
HER FATHER AND MOTHER LYNNE
CHENEY WERE WATCHING HER SPEECH
LAST NIGHT, A SHORT DISTANCE
FROM THE STAGE, AND I WAS
LOOKING AT THEM AS THEY WERE
LOOKING AT THEIR DAUGHTER AND
CERTAINLY THE END OF AN ERA FOR
THE CHENEYS IN A VERY DIFFERENT
REPUBLICAN PARTY HERE IN WYOMING
AND INDEED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>>> AND JOINING US NOW TO
DISCUSS, CNN CHIEF NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT AND THE ANCHOR OF
"INSIDE POLITICS" JOHN KING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
DAY.
CAN YOU JUST PUT INTO CONTEXT
THIS MORNING IN HISTORY WHERE
YOU GO FROM LIZ CHENEY TWO YEARS
AGO WINNING BY MORE THAN -- SHE
WINS WITH MORE THAN 70% OF THE
VOTE, AND HERE SHE GETS CREAMED
WITH A SPREAD OF MORE THAN 30%,
EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS DEMOCRATS
GOING TO HER SIDE.
>> SHE STOOD UP TO TRUMP AND
TRUMP GOT 70% OF THE VOTE IN
CONSERVATIVE WYOMING AND THIS IS
THE DEFINING FIGHT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY RIGHT NOW.
SHE KNEW IT.
SHE EXPLAINED LAST NIGHT, SHE
HAD A CHOICE, SHE HAD A CHOICE,
JOIN HER LEADER, KEVIN McCARTHY
IN THE HOUSE IN TELLING A LIE,
REPEATING A LIE, SUPPORTING A
LIE THAT SOMEHOW DONALD TRUMP
WAS CHEATED IN 2020, OR STAND UP
FOR IT.
SO I'M MORE FASCINATED BY THE
NEXT CHAPTER.
THIS WAS WYOMING IS WYOMING TO
JEFF'S POINT, HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE, MAYBE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE INDEPENDENTS AND
DEMODEMOCRAT
SWITCH PARTIES TO STAND WITH LIZ
CHENEY BUT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH.
>> WE JUST HAD SOME NEWS A FEW
MINUTES AGO, LIZ CHENEY IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH SAVANNAH GUTHRIE
SAID SHE'S NOT ABOUT TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT IN A WAY SHE
DID, I'M CONSIDERING.
I'M DECIDING RIGHT NOW WHETHER
I'M GOING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT IS DECLARING SOMETHING.
>> IT IS.
FIRST CONTEST FOR THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION IS 17 OR 18 MONTHS
AWAY.
SHE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION MONTHS AND MONTHS
BEFORE THAT TO ORGANIZE.
SO EVERYBODY SHOULD THINK ABOUT
THAT, EVERYBODY SHOULD WATCH
THAT, AND THAT'S THE BIG
FLASHING LIGHT.
I'M MUCH MORE INTERESTED IN THE
NEXT THREE, FOUR MONTHS.
WHAT SHE SAID LAST NIGHT IN HER
SPEECH, I URGE ALL AMERICANS NOT
TO VOTE FOR ELECTION DENIERS.
SO NOW SHE HAS THE SUPER PAC.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS LEFT
OVER SHE RAISED IN THE WYOMING
RACE.
CAN THEY PROVE IT?
THIS IS THE TEST.
YOU WILL LEARN ABOUT WHAT YOU
CAN DO, CAN YOU MOVE VOTERS, CAN
YOU BEAT TRUMP, CAN YOU BEAT
ELECTION DENIERS, YOU'LL KNOW
MORE ABOUT THAT TERRAIN IN 2024
IF YOU TRY IT AND PLAY HARD IN
2022.
SO WILL THEY RAISE MONEY?
WILL THEY RUN ADS?
AND THEN CAN THEY GO OUT AND
CAMPAIGN AND CAN YOU CONVINCE
ENOUGH REPUBLICANS IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES LIKE
ARIZONA, LIKE PENNSYLVANIA,
ELSEWHERE, TO NOT SUPPORT
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES?
CAN YOU CONVINCE REPUBLICANS
THIS IS MORE IMPORTANT AND SO
CAN YOU SWITCH THE HOUSE THERE?
NO.
I THINK THE DYNAMICS IN THE
HOUSE SEEM PRETTY CLEAR.
BUT YOU COULD MAKE AN IMPACT IN
SOME KEY GOVERNOR RACES AND KEY
SENATE RACES AND IT IS A
LABORATORY, IF YOU WILL.
>> YOU THINK THIS IS A TEST RUN
TO SEE HOW MUCH OF A SPOILER SHE
CAN BE.
>> SHE DOES NOT WASTE WORDS.
WHY DID SHE SAY THAT LAST NIGHT?
I URGE ALL AMERICANS, MEANING
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS UP
IN PLAY IN THE ELECTION YEAR,
NORMALLY A DEMOCRAT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, THEREFORE HIS PARTY GETS
PUNISHED IN THE MIDTERM ELECTION
YEAR, BUT SHE WAS LOOKING
STRAIGHT AHEAD AND SAYING, THIS
SAY MOMENT, THIS IS A MOMENT OF
CHOOSING.
THE REPUBLICAN MOMENT OF
CHOOSING ABOUT TRUMP WILL COME
IN 2024.
THERE IS A LOT OF TIME BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN.
IN OUR BUSINESS, AND IN POLITICS
SOMETIMES WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
GET -- SKIP CHAPTERS.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A PRETTY
FASCINATING DRAMA.
WE SHOULD GO ONE PAGE AT A TIME.
>> WHAT WOULD MAKE HER SAY, NO,
I'M NOT GOING TO RUN AGAINST
TRUMP IF SHE FELT PERHAPS SHE
WAS GOING TO JUST PLAY THE FOIL
AND HELP HIM?
>> THERE ARE SERIOUS
CONVERSATIONS AMONG LIZ CHENEY,
LARRY HOGAN, PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
ABOUT WHAT DOES IT TAKE?
WHAT IF A BUNCH OF US RAN AS
ANTI-TRUMP CANDIDATES?
DO WE NEED JUST ONE?
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
THE FIRST QUESTION IS MIKE PENCE
IS GOING TO BE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
THIS MORNING AT THE POLITICS
BREAKFAST.
WHAT DOES HE SAY ABOUT THIS?
DOES IT MAKE HIM MORE DEFIANT
AND MORE STAND UP TO TRUMP?
DO YOU SAY, LOOK WHAT HAPPENED
IN WYOMING, TRUMP IS THE TAIL
THAT WAGS THE DOG AND I'M GOING
TO MUTE MYSELF?
IF YOU'RE WATCHING, DOES RON
DeSANTIS, IF TRUMP RUNS, DOES HE
HAVE THE COURAGE TO RUN.
DONALD TRUMP RUN BECAUSE HE HAD
THE 16 CANDIDATES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE RACE.
YOU HAD RUBIO, BUSH, CRUZ, RAND
PAUL.
AND TRUMP WON EARLY ON BECAUSE
HE WAS GETTING 30% OF THE VOTE.
IF THERE IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
TRUMPIAN CANDIDATES, TRUMP-LIKE
CANDIDATES AND ONE ANTI-TRUMPER
RUNS, STRONG ANTI-TRUMPER, YOU
CAN GET 25%, MAYBE 30%.
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE '22 TEST,
HOW MUCH CAN YOU GET?
CAN YOU LEARN HOW MUCH YOU CAN
GET AS YOU HEAD INTO 2024?
LET'S BE HONEST, WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT TRUMP WILL LOOK LIKE IN 16
OR 17 OR 18 MONTHS.
JUST IN PART BECAUSE OF ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS, IN PART BECAUSE
YOU DO FIND FOR REPUBLICANS, WHO
SUPPORT WHAT HE SAYS, WHO DENY
THE ELECTION, WHICH IS JUST
WRONG, WHO JUST SAY, THOUGH, BUT
CAN HE WIN AGAIN?
FOR ALL THE MOCKING OF JOE BIDEN
THEY DO, IN A DARK ROOM, WHETHER
OR NOT ON CAMERA, REPUBLICANS
HAVE TO REALIZE, JOE BIDEN BEAT
DONALD TRUMP AND BEAT HIM PRETTY
GOOD.
>> THAT'S THE MIKE PENCE
ARGUMENT.
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT FROM PENCE
WORLD THAT THEY'LL WHISPER TO
YOU, TRUMP LOST.
>> LOOK, I'M FASCINATED BY IT.
THIS IS WHAT I DO.
I CAN STAY AT THE MAP ALL DAY
LONG LOOKING AT 2024 STATES AND
WHICH PRIMARIES COULD LIZ CHENEY
DO WELL IN.
I THINK THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS
JUST THAT'S EXCITING, THAT'S
INTERESTING.
BUT IT IS WAY TOO FAR DOWN THE
ROAD.
ANYONE WHO TELLS YOU THEY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN HERE,
IGNORE THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE JUST LIVE IN THE INCREDIBLY
VOLATILE TIMES.
PEOPLE SAID WE'RE NOT READY FOR
A BLACK PRESIDENT.
THERE IS NO WAY DONALD TRUMP CAN
WIN.
THAT WAS A FLUKE.
THERE IS NO WAY HE CAN WIN THE
PRESIDENCY.
JOE BIDEN IS 2020, THERE IS NO
WAY HE CAN WIN.
JUST TAKE IT ONE DAY AT A TIME.
>> SHE INVOKED LINCOLN AND THE
FACT SHE LOST HOUSE AND SENATE
RACES BEFORE GOING ON TO BE
PRESIDENT, DID YOU TAKE THAT TO
MEAN SHE WAS LIKENING HERSELF TO
LINCOLN?
OR DID YOU TAKE THAT MAYBE AS
BOTH TO MEAN SHE WAS SAYING TO
REPUBLICANS, LOOK AT THE LONG
GAME.
JUST BECAUSE YOU LOSE THE BATTLE
DOESN'T MEAN YOU SHOULDN'T KEEP
YOUR EYE ON WINNING THE WAR?
>> I THINK BOTH.
BOTH.
I THINK SHE WAS TRYING TO SAY
SOME FIGHTS ARE WORTH FIGHTING.
TAKING THE RISK, EVEN IF YOU MAY
LOSE.
LINCOLN DID NOT IN THE END.
HE SURVIVED.
BUT IT WAS A RISK.
AND THE OTHER THING IS THAT THE
REPUBLICANS, PLEASE, PLEASE,
PLEASE, THIS IS A PROUD PARTY,
WITH A GREAT LEGACY, AND A GREAT
HISTORY, CAN WE HAVE IT BACK,
PLEASE?
WHAT HAPPENED TO SMALLER
GOVERNMENT?
WHERE ARE THE MARKET SOLUTIONS?
JOE BIDEN SIGNED A HUGE POLICY
ACHIEVEMENT YESTERDAY.
A HUGE POLICY ACHIEVEMENT.
IT DOES BIG THINGS IN
HEALTHCARE.
BUT FIRST TIME MAKES GIANT
INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE.
REPUBLICANS ALL VOTED NO.
LIZ CHENEY WANTS THE REPUBLICANS
TO HAVE A PLAN.
HERE IS A MARKET APPROACH TO THE
HEALTHCARE SOLUTIONS, THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED IN THE COUNTRY.
BIG POLICY DEBATES ABOUT BIG
CHALLENGES AND LET THEM VOTE AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND WE
HAVE ELECTIONS.
WE'RE GONE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS NOT A
POLICY DRIVEN PARTY ANYMORE.
AN IDEOLOGICAL PARTY ANYMORE.
IT IS A TRUMP PARTY.
AND IT IS A GRIEVANCE PARTY.
IT IS A PARTY BUILT ON THE IDEA
THAT JOE BIDEN IS NOT A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT, WHICH IS
NOT JUST FACTUAL.
THEY HAVE STOOD ON THAT GROUND,
QUICK SAND, LONGER THAN MANY
PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY COULD, BUT
EVENTUALLY YOU SINK IN QUICK
SAND.